thank you very much dear friends and
colleagues first of all I would like to
thank our host prime minister Sanchez di
Pedro for convening us here uh this EPC
Summit behind the European political
Community is an
idea the idea that the European
Community can and must shape its own
future we're Bound by a common geography
and by Common history and this fact has
shaped our shared values and
rules for decades we Europeans have
built a security architecture that is
based on the UN Charter and
international law now this security
architecture is under
threat a permanent member of the UN
Security Council has launched an attack
on its peaceful neighbor and this attack
goes on since
days it is Our obligation that Ukraine
prevails and not the right of Might it
is Our obligation that the European
security architecture is
reestablished so that on this continent
all Europeans can live in Peace and
Freedom and this must guide us here in
EPC
these principles are also shaping this
agenda take
energy this is my second point we have
worked hard to ensure our energy
security and to make energy affordable
for our European
households and we can be proud how we
mastered the severe energy crisis of
last winter for instance we're now
buying energy
together not only with 27 EU member
states but with our broader energy
Community together with Ukraine mova
Norway and Serbia and the UK is anyhow
integrated in the energy exchange this
has brought Energy prices down today our
storages are
filled we got rid of the dependency on
Russian fossil fuels as you said it
rightly
sadimir and thanks to this we have
turned Putin's energy blackmail into an
empty threat so I encourage all of us to
look at how we can best replicate this
success in other fields from clean
energy to raw
materials and as we protect people we
have also to strive to protect our
planet for the first time ever the
European Union is now producing more
electricity from
Renewables like wind and Sun than from
gas and and this is not only good for
our planet but it is also creating good
jobs here in Europe while securing
energy
Independence and my third and final
Point Europe has always been a continent
of pioneers and
innovators and we should continue to
explore the frontiers of innovation also
in artificial
intelligence the potential of artificial
intelligence is immense in fields
ranging from Health Care to farming and
many others but we also need to protect
Europeans from the risks of unregulated
AI the European Union has put forward
the world's first comprehensive and
pro-innovation
AI
act it is a human Centric approach it
will take some time to implement it so
now we need a globally coordinated ated
response and dialogue with companies so
that they voluntarily commit to a
values-based and ethical use of AI let
us join forces here too in pushing for
Global governance of artificial
intelligence all the challenges we Face
from collective security to Ai call for
common European answer and this is the
spirit of the European political
community let us continue to make the
most out of it let us continue to
believe that we are more than a
continent we are a community of Destiny
thank you very
much thank
you
[Applause]